the news just keeps getting better and
better for the country and the guy
leading it today the government reported
that jobless claims fell in June to
their lowest level in 44 years layoffs
are also way down near a 50-year low and
223,000 jobs were added to the economy
in May
voters are feeling the improvement in
the economy and the rewarding President
Trump with higher approval ratings a new
Wall Street journal/nbc poll has the
president at 44% the highest ever in
that poll which is also on par with
where Reagan was in 1982 and where Obama
was in 2010 pretty good at the same time
the president is trying to expand his
base which is really smart while making
gains with african-americans trying to
has been a dream of traditional
Republicans for a long time this
president actually might find some
progress unemployment is at a record low
for blacks and near record low for
Hispanics it's great news and his
administration is working really hard on
prison reform which let's face it would
have an enormous ly positive effect on
African American families and after that
nudge from the realities to our Kim
Kardashian Donald Trump commuted the
sentence of Alice Johnson she's been a
model prisoner for serving a life
sentence for drug conspiracy and money
laundering and she offered these words
to President Trump today thank you so
much that I am going to be that one that
is going to make you so proud and I hope
that my life will encourage him to do
this for others now putting the merits
of this particular case aside for a
moment this is a really smart political
move by the president sharp now just
maybe this will spark a conversation
among black voters who are traditionally
skeptical let's face it about the
Republican Party maybe more will give a
second look at Trump and his policies
despite what certain pro athletes
certain civil rights activist jesse
jackson is going to be joining us
shortly our saying about him so while
Republicans make inroads with new voters
what does the other party do well the
party that once stood for the workingman
the Democrats has now taken a radical
turn as former Bill Clinton pollster
Doug Schon told me this week that's why
I am so upset with the current direction
of the Democratic Party where the
progressive left is pushing the party
farther and farther we distribute resist
guaranteed jobs guaranteed health care
but no individual initiative now having
abandoned in the middle of the country
basically the Democrats reflexively
protect and defend fringe causes and
individuals with absolutely no
constituency case-in-point pornstar
stormy Daniels the other day in Israel
Rudy Giuliani a member of the
president's legal team offered this
personal appraisal of stormy Daniels I
respect all human beings even have to
respect you know criminals I'm sorry I
don't respect a pornstar the way I
respect a career woman or a woman of
substance her body for sexual
exploitation now one can quibble over
whether Giuliani should have gone down
this road at all but the manufactured
and selective moral indignation all over
the media today including from the
ladies of the view was totally over the
top first of all I just want to say that
we interviewed stormy Daniels on the
show there's no reason anyone should
question this woman's credibility sex
work is work and like any other business
it's bad with ba laws criminalizing
consensual transactional sex it is legal
it's K it's consensual by the way the
only industry where women make more
money than men okay
[Applause]
we've always had women who worked and
worked on the streets a lot of them have
put their kids through college they have
had incredible lives gone on to do all
kinds of stuff so the mere fact that you
would make such a blanket statement
about someone you don't know who does
something you seemingly know nothing
about seems kind of shocking I don't
know just say how about that man I'm not
often speechless but well I'm glad the
left found a cause that they can rally
to I don't remember their standing in
support of another sister
well Melania Trump when she was being
defamed or Ivanka Trump when Samantha
bee went on the attack or frankly Sarah
Sanders when that filthy comedian whose
name Aleut eludes me was it
Maggie something attacked her at the
White House Correspondents Dinner and
what about the women who claimed they
were sexually abused by Bill Clinton
Juanita Broderick Paula Jones and
Kathleen Willey earlier this week
Gennifer Flowers join me for an
exclusive and made this charge he came
on to me that night I told him to knock
it off he proceeded to continue to come
on to me for three months in hindsight
it was definitely sexual harassment I
would like for the me2 movement to be so
kind as to recognize myself and Paul and
Juanita and Kathleen and many many other
women starting many years ago that have
come out with claims of of sexual
harassment from Bill Clinton gals on the
view had nothing to say about that
not one word I guess some women are just
beyond respectability not worthy of it
when Chris Cuomo broached the topic with
Chuck Schumer last night this is the
response that he got Bill Clinton said
about me to a lot of controversy your
take not getting into that because
I think it's irrelevant to what we need
to talk about is they make nice news but
it doesn't help the course so when those
accusers are irrelevant imagine four
Republicans said that about another one
we run off television the only woman
worthy of the less left's embrace right
now at this last 24 hours is a porn star
who happens to be suing the president
Mika Brzezinski and Stephanie ruhle were
undone by Rudy's comments he says look
at her and laughs derisively what a pig
with my know your value platform feel
really strongly about these comments and
they made my blood boil this is a really
bad day for women if this is exactly the
person the president wants speaking for
him it's a bad day for Humanity it goes
down to value a bad day for Humanity
there's no overstatement there
whatsoever oh please come on guys
imagine for instance if after four years
of college and a slog to put your kid
through school your daughter through
school and any one of our daughters
announced that she wanted to be a porn
star or maybe a stripper okay what
mother wouldn't be making a value
judgment about that vocational choice oh
great honey
that's fantastic hanging off a stripper
pole is a much better choice than
Business School yay the selective
outrage and the twisted morality the
left never fails to amaze me but through
all this the Democrats have revealed
themselves well nothing else to run on
they now have become essentially the
party of ms-13 not animals
I guess transgender bathrooms open
borders NFL protests filthy comedians
partial birth abortion oh and let's
throw in pot oh and now the porn
industry can you put that on a bumper
sticker we'll see how that plays in
November and that's the angle